Build it.
Draw it.
Play it.
Vsauce!
This is your home for some of the coolest
creations from everyday people.
This is BiDiPi.
BUILD IT
In the Arizona desert, Ernie Adams is building
miniature versions of classic cars by hand
from scratch, including a 1939 Chevy Sedan,
a 1929 Ford Hillbilly, and a 1949 Mercury.
Adams even builds the tools that are necessary
for the creations and it takes him between
1 and 5 years to construct each one.
He calls them Dwarf Cars and some are even
street legal.
And they're on display at the Dwarf Car Museum
in Arizona
Domenico Crolla makes celebrity-inspired pizza
art including Gordon Ramsey, Rhianna, Donald
Trump, Mortal Kombat, and Tom Ford but he
says although he doesn't want to be typecast
as a pizza chef he happens to be very good
at making pizza and its his favorite food.
Reconnected is an art installation by Phillipe
Handford in Pendle England at the location
of where an infamous hanging took place over
400 years ago.
Bridging the past and present day cruelty,
Handford decided to connect the stumps of
fallen trees cut down illegally by using metal
frames that look like spines so the trees
appear frozen in time when they fell.
Radek Michalowski made this MIG-23 fighter
jet arcade cabinet that was inspired by living
near the gate of a fighter air regiment in
Poland.
It's numbered 846 in tribute to a plane that
his friend's father flew.
And it's for sale on Etsy for $3,358.75
DRAW IT
Artist Natalie Eve Garrett created this series
of fairy tale art made out of yogurt including
characters like Goldilocks, Rapunzel, Little
Red Riding Hood, and the Little Mermaid
Adrien Noterdaem "simpsonized" the game of
thrones characters by illustrating each character
as they would be seen on The Simpsons.
Just of few of the characters are Joffrey,
Daenerys Targaryen, Khal Drogo, and Tyrion
Lannister.
Check out his site for more simsonized characters
And now for the surrealistic art of Moscow
based artist Dmitry Maximov
Uncured is photo series by Ben Dehaan of melting
portraits.
He used a type of printer where the ink dries
using UV light but disabled that function
so the photos slowly dripped.
And then he photographed the dripping to create
this effect.
PLAY IT
Here is a really cool bass cover of Daft Punk's
"Get Lucky" by Jim Bennett
YouTuber Chad Neldt created this one minute
mash up of 20 famous commercial jingles
Artist Mauro Ffortissimo is installing pianos
along the coastline of Northern California
for his project "Sunset Piano Opus Two for
Twelve Pianos" where 12 pianos have been made
available to the public so anyone can play
them
at anytime.
Finally, direct from Sweden here's the metal
version of Nox Aurumque done by Vsauce fans
Means End, composed by Eric Whitacre - and
this guy's voice is seriously awesome.
Submit your BiDiPis as a personal message
here on YouTube.
Or share them with everyone over at Facebook.com/VsauceTwo.
Click here to listen to a brand new installment
of BiDiPi Radio - music created and submitted
by you guys.
Also check out Your BiDIPi - an entire video
dedicated to your creations.
This is the 200th Vsauce2 video, which seems
incredible, and I just wanted to thank all
of you that have been with the channel since
day one and those of you who just recently
subscribed and found these videos.
Y'know someone on Twitter recently sent me
a message saying, "I love your videos - please
keep making them!"
And I immediately thought, "Well, yeah!
Why would I stop?"
You guys are literally the coolest audience
and with so many amazing things happening
all around the world to talk about..
Will there be 200 more videos?
I don't know.
You're just gonna have to stick around and
find out.
And as always - thanks for watching.